foreign
now I can't see you but hopefully you
can see me
okay let's just do this the way you used
to hello everybody I'm making in this
video now
none of that later today however there's
a video going up you might want to check
it out it's not about vlogging today is
about vlogging
um and we're going to go straight into
the topic I hope you're having a great I
was about to say NDC Copenhagen
developer Festival can have a oh if yay
still awake at 20 past 10. let's see how
that goes after lunch
so
quick introduction for those of you who
don't know me
um hello everybody my name is Nick
chapsis I make YouTube videos primarily
and just to check how many of you know
me from YouTube
I see some hands that are not raised
please take out your phone right now and
subscribe
it is free it doesn't cost anything it
makes me feel very very nice
no I'm a bunch of other things Microsoft
and vpa yes whatever
um I turned to 30 in April which means
you can legally make a podcast now when
I did make one so keep coding podcast I
only have like seven episodes but we
have more coming uh from September and
I'm also the founder and author at a
platform called Dome train where we
create educational courses for things
like logging minimal apis and so on you
might want to check it out
now
I want to ask a question how many of you
have actually seen this talk already on
YouTube from NDC Oslo I see some hands
what the hell are you doing here
thanks for being here this usually
happens the first talk but this
presented will go up
um as you might say and now I wanted to
say it has changed since you saw it but
that's not the case so I'm sorry
you're gonna watch the same thing but
I'm here
I want to talk about the title now just
just for a second
because
well it's a bit obnoxious isn't it
you're doing logging wrong like like how
do I know that you're doing it wrong
well I don't in fact you might many of
you might be doing it right now
for you this talk will be more of a
validation that yeah okay indeed I'm
doing everything right or you might find
something that you don't know about
um but I want to talk about something
that happened in the previous conference
back in I think November or April and
that was in Romania
so I was in.net days and Rachel Apple
was giving the keynote which was all
about dark patterns and how people try
to get you to click on things that
well ads mostly or let's say you have an
audible subscription audible will do its
best to get you to not
um unsubscribe and so on
and she was talking about clickbait at
this specific point and well I thought
the screen will turn into like this
because if you know anything about my
YouTube videos I'm not saying I'm click
baiting but I'm certainly pushing it is
all I'm gonna say but if you have to
know one thing about clickbait is that
it actually works so don't hate the
player hate the game
and that's why this title was selected
for this talk this is a phone room
obviously
um so you're wondering okay what can I
learn here
now the last thing I want to address
before I go into the the main body of
the presentation is that some people
will tell you that you don't need
logging at all in today's day and age we
have open Telemetry the Spanish is all
you need traces whatever
um and logging you shouldn't even worry
about now in a utopian an Ideal World
maybe that's that's true maybe where we
can all start with Evergreen projects
everything.net 8 from scratch then maybe
that could be the case but I do
understand that not everyone is in this
situation and even if you do start from
scratch
that doesn't mean that logging isn't
needed even then it is needed audit logs
some would argue debugging tracing but
why do I say that well because there's
this individual here who's also a
speaker he had a talk yesterday
unfortunately so I can't redirect you to
his talk name Martin twaites any of you
know Martin anyone been on the talk yes
awesome yeah Martin are you here
no you're not
your loss
but um he's very much an advocate for
not doing logging or very small amount
of logging
but he's interesting guy but here's the
interesting thing about Martin let's
take a look at his LinkedIn profile and
see where he works hmm he's a principal
developer advocate for honeycomb which
is a company about observability spans
metrics and tracing and all that how
convenient that he advocates for the
things that makes him money
so what you should know when you see
speakers on stage talking about things
like this is that everyone has an
ulterior motive everyone wants to either
promote their career the business the
website so take everything you you hear
on the stage and any other stage with a
grain of salt on a completely unrelated
note I have a logging course on my
website
for 69.99 you can actually Master this
topic I have to work on my Segways a bit
because I think this came across as
anyway so let's talk about the talk now
the talk is not about any of these
things I'm going to show you now
and I want you to raise your hand by the
way this talk is very raise your hand
heavy so after 10 reps you might want to
use the other one so you have equal
shoulders
do you know what local is
great do you know what SEC is more hands
great
um cloudwatch AWS cloudwords yay how
about application insights do we know
that hey Microsoft look at all those
hands you sell out
how about datadog do we know what that
is yeah you don't pay the bill for that
someone else pays a bill for that
do you know how expensive that is if you
mess it up
at this point I would make a joke about
gcp but I don't know what they have
there I don't even think it's a real
Cloud platform like anyone using gcp
I'm sorry
I've heard it great like all six people
like it
is this talk really about right well
it's about this fundamentally it is
about
your code your c-sharp that is doing any
sort of logging if you've written a line
of code like this ever in your life this
talk is for you
but
as I'll be going through this this talk
you might be like Nick
you know I think what you're trying to
do is you're trying to sell us a
performance talk as a logging talk
and will certainly feel that way at some
stages but please bear with me
there's a reason
rewind there's a reason why
um that's the case and that is because a
byproduct like a happy accident of doing
logging right is a great increase in
your applications performance
so don't think that everything I'm
talking about when I'm talking about
performance is that we're doing this
because of performance but I want you to
understand the benefit of what you're
getting on top of beta logging
and ultimately this is about the real
world these are things that I've seen
being done wrong I've done them wrong I
keep seeing them on code bases all the
time and the very easy mistakes to fix
once you understand the meaning behind
them
now I want to ask a question what is
this
I want to be more specific what is this
what is this supposed to be representing
this value this hello this parameter
anyone can shout what it is
it's a string great what is supposed to
represent
log message
message
information
what
measures template let's see what
Microsoft says this is supposed to be
the message
it's not the message it's the message
template
so let's start this talk with a bit of a
theme and I'm going to have my eight
logging rules that you can follow or
note I don't care one thing I should
point out however is that
apart from a couple which I will tell
you ahead of time that they are heavily
subjective and you don't have to follow
them
the rest are objective it's things that
you should be doing
no questions asked it's not about
personal opinion it's about that's how
you should do it and because.net has
changed so much over the years
well some people are still doing them
wrong so the first rule is the message
is actually the message template and
it's arbitrated as such and we're going
to see in this talk what this means but
I'm going to show you a few lines of
code and I'm going to ask you if you are
doing any of these on your logs don't
worry this is not a trap question I just
want you to be engaged
and if you use string interpolation in
your logs
nice how about string concatenation
not so much because I guess
interpolation replaces that how about
string template um templating and
formatting yeah but this approach right
with the zero and then yeah so it was a
trap question all of these are wrong so
if you're doing any of this then you're
in the right room
but I'm going to start with the first
one which is one of my favorite c-sharp
features actually and if you're still in
Java or if someone of you is doing Java
they still haven't figured this one out
and that is string interpolation
so what is string interpolation well it
came in the C sharp six or seven I want
to say
and let's say we take this message and
we want to parameterize it so username
chaps is just in fact
now we could do this with string
concatenation so we can have the the
quote double quotes and then plus and
then so on and so forth and build the
same string using multiple strings like
this
or we could use string.comcat now behind
the scenes what's happening in C sharp
is actually that that second line will
be compiled into that third line
so those two things are basically the
same
now you could also have a string.format
where you can have indexed parameters in
your message template and you can say
zero is name one is age and so on
and you can mix and match as well so you
can have one earlier and and zero later
but when string interpolation came out
we got this where you can have this
dollar sign in the beginning and then
Kelly braces and then
who can say name here in h here and as
you can see it's just a way more elegant
solution than what we really were using
before which was the string
concatenation
now one thing you have to know about
c-sharp especially all the way until C
sharp 11 and 12 now is that the weight
was shipped with net made it very
dangerous to add features that
fundamentally changed where c-sharp runs
and that is the CLR because c-sharp is
compiled into IL code and that IL code
those instructions are what we
ultimately have executed
and why is that well that's because of
updating or if something is breaking and
you have a service pack too on your
Windows machine then it's very hard to
make sure everyone installs the new
version just it's just a mess so
how c-sharp features were added until C
sharp 11 and 12 is through syntactic
sugar so what we had is through the
process of lowering we would get
features are higher as high as higher
versions of lower features which means
that for example string interpolation is
no different the in fact the only
feature or features that we have now in
C sharp 12 and 11 that fundamentally
change the CLR to be able to be
accommodated are generics on attributes
and that virtual abstract static thing
on the interfaces those two things
require the CLR change but it's fine now
because c-sharp or net is released
not bi-weekly every two weeks with
patches so if that was an issue they
could easily patch that
and string interpolation is no different
in fact all the way until C sharp nine
if you wrote a message like the top one
what the compiler would do behind the
scenes is just a string dot format
why is this bad and why am I going into
this tangent about strings well it's bad
because of this both for format and
concat you might be able to spot it I'm
going to give you a bit of a hint
these things are bad if you've ever
tried to write high performance C sharp
whenever you see parameters of an object
array
Mega red flag or run or fix it
and that has to do with how c-sharp
deals with memory so memory is allocated
in two places in c-sharp you might have
heard them it's the stack and the Heap
neck
what what the hell I thought this is a
logging talk
it will make sense so let's take a look
at the two different places where we can
allocate memory
so the first one is a stack let's assume
I have something like this let's avoid
method and also assume that nothing will
be optimized the way of the method
because some people try to get clever
with saying yeah the compiler will
remove all of these parameters because
nothing is using it assume that they are
used
so what I have here is an integer which
is a value type
I have a good which is also a value type
because it's a struct and I have a point
to D that for the purposes of this
demonstration assume that it is also a
struct which is a value type
the way this will be allocated on the
memory is in a very local thing to what
we call the stack frame which is what we
have in this method and it's going to
look something like this so we're going
to say put 30 on stack in position zero
put the good in position two
um or one I can't do indexing then two
and three now if you want to be very
pedantic there's actually more going on
behind the scenes to accommodate this
track but don't worry fundamentally or
conceptually that's what's going on
behind the scenes
and the good thing about this is that
this memory is only used within the
stack frame and once we're outside the
stack frame it can be automatically
disposed not garbage collected mind you
but just disappear out of existence
because we can guarantee for a fact that
nothing else needs this and because
those are value types and they're
allocated locally we can just dispose
them
no garbage collection
the Heap on the other hand is quite
different in this example assume that
both person and point to D are reference
types they're classes and reference
types are always allocated on the hip
the hip is another area somewhere we
don't really know exactly where it is
and you can think of it the way I like
to think of it it's like just a
dictionary with Blobs of memory floating
in space you can tell I'm not that
technical on the subject and they all
have an address sort of an ID saying
that okay if you want the person then
the person is on this location and if
you want the point to D the point of D
is there there can be miles apart it
doesn't really matter they're not local
but because of how they're allocated and
how they can be used we can never really
be sure who's using it so what we're
doing is we're allocating there we also
don't know their size that's another
reason why
we might want to do that or while we're
doing it and we say okay they use that
allocate there there might be some
references to it at some point later
let's see how many of those don't have
any references to it and then garbage
collector
so let's see how the two compare
so we have the stack and we have the
Heap the stack is where value types can
be allocated now it's not where they
always allocated the value types can
also be allocated on the Heap and we're
going to see how
also local variables and parameters
let's say you have a class they can also
be allocated there
sorry a method not a class it's very
fast and it automatically disappears
when out of scope we do not expect a
garbage collection event to clear out
that memory
now the Heap is where reference types
are always allocated and it's sort of a
big pool of memory and it needs to be
garbage collected so boxed value types
can be allocated here
now what is boxing I will explain what
boxing is by taking a look at this graph
over here
so any of you have seen this
showing how Microsoft tells you that
dotnet is the best thing ever in
existence and the fastest thing as well
yeah Microsoft made this
it is not
objective but it's not subjective you
can read more on how this is generated
but the reason why I'm bringing it up is
because the way.net has gotten that fast
is by actually eliminating a lot of the
hip allocations that cause garbage
collection which in return cause
inconsistency in performance and slows
application down
and a bit of a self-promotion as well in
the podcast I had Stephen Tob who is a
genius performance guy in Microsoft
where we spent three hours talking about
things like that and I pretend like I
can understand what he's saying I'm not
asleep I'm just blinking maybe not the
best frame to choose for this
so what is boxing and why am I so
against it well
let's take a look at this method we have
an integer elf um called age and we
assign the age to be third and then we
return it
now I don't really know IL but I know
how to copy it from my ID so I'm just
going to paste it here so this line will
be translated into this line when I
compile my code all this really says is
that you put an integer with value
thread in this location on the stack and
again later then just get it and do
something with it
and that's very cheap very easy no magic
involved however if I have the same
thing but as you can see I convert that
implicitly to an object because I can't
convert any type to an object then the
instruction actually changes not only do
we allocate on the stack but we also box
it into an int32 object this boxing
process over here is what will make this
value actually go on the Heap so I have
an object type so I have a value type
converted into a reference type which
has to go on the Heap and then that
causes the device to be allocated
presumably in this case for no reason
and this goes both ways by the way so
you have unboxing as well
so you have unbox that parameter and
then return it
now
why is that all bad
ultimately this because you're gonna
create so much garbage out of it and as
we've established garbage needs to be
garbage collected and that's what slows
application down
so let's take a look at the two main
reasons
crap
and then a ton of strings can also cause
tons of crap because strings are not
special I mean technically they are they
are reference type or reference types
are compared based on their values but
they're not also not magic many people
think that we have this word called the
string interning which makes you think
that each string is allocated once per
value of the string in memory and then
reused using its memory address and this
is only true for string compile time
string literals all the ones forced
manually during runtime it won't be done
for every string
so even if you're Computing the same
string over and over and over and over
again that string multiple times will be
allocated in your memory and that will
come again into the picture when we talk
about logging that's why I'm giving you
all this background so more boxing means
more hip allocations which means
um more work to set and retrieve values
which means more gaps collections
triggered which means more pausing which
means inconsistency in performance and
imagine you're building a game or
something that needs to be on a frame by
frame precision
well this can really screw you up
more strings mean more hip allocations
because they are reference types and
they're expensive reference types as
well they're heavy types which means
more garbage collections more pausing
which means more time to clean things up
but you might say Nick
string interpolation handlers fix that
and that is true in C sharp 10 we got an
amazing feature called string
interpolation handlers and it looks
something like this so before this thing
would be converted to a string.format
which would box because it uses the
parameters object array
however from C sharp 10 onwards all that
will be converted to this beauty
which is a lot but thankfully you don't
have to write it but let's talk about it
first you have to know if you have to
know this is a ref struct always
allocated On The Stack
not only that but that 16 or sorry 19
and 2 that you see on its instantiation
has to do with the size of the string
that we are passing the literal size of
the string and then the number of
parameters we're going to pass in this
case two parameters the name and the age
and the most important thing about all
this all this is that the appended
append formatted method that accepts an
integer the age uses a generic whenever
you see generics in C sharp you're
actually preventing the process of
boxing so by having the compiler detect
all that in compile time we don't have
to worry about it in runtime saving us
more memory and if you've been in C
shops in C sharp one where we didn't
have generics I say we I wasn't there
we have we had an array list that
accepted objects and you had to cast
them out of whatever type they were to
use them
um in C chapter we got generics and
thankfully we did it better than Java so
well
and it's funny because Matt storgensen
who is obviously the lead for c-sharp
was actually responsible for generics in
Java or part of the team
so I call it sabotage
so by doing all that yes we are saving
that boxing and allocation but we still
have all of those strings being
allocated once per unique entry so if
you have like let's say a name and a
grid or a name a good an age or a good
enablement age and a daytime parameter
and you use that in a string you're
going to create an amount of string as
many of your log invocations and those
are unique strings that are being
allocated in your memory
let's visualize that because all that
might just go over your head
so if you profile your application doing
that which is just generating these
strings for login purposes then your
memory will look something like this
where we have these spikes going on and
then down and on and down and on and
down and memory pressure will depend on
whatever metal you're running this on
but fundamentally as you can see we go
all the way up to 16 megabytes and then
something happens so we go down what
happens is garbage collection and you
can see that by actually me highlighting
this bit which is microseconds of
pausing your application completely
everything to just say okay
let's count how many of you don't have
any references this this this this this
okay let's clean it and your strings
will be part of this at some point
so the more you allocate the more of
this happens the more it needs to be
garbage collected the more your
application is pausing
so rule number two
I shall not use string interpolation or
concatenation in the message template
but what should you use if you can't use
those amazing features of C sharp well
structure logging
so let's consider the following we have
this log message where actually this is
very close to what I was doing when I
was working for a payment provider and
we have a look at DOT log and then
payment with ID whatever string
interpolation failed with status
whatever and if I do that and I push it
into application insights then I'm going
to see something like this I'm going to
have payment with ID it's fantastic it's
great I'm getting all the information I
need and when business comes and says oh
we had this massive incident and
production went down and the validation
service just clicked the bucket and we
had to go back and find all the canceled
payments then you're like oh I know what
I can do because I can see that all of
this ends with requires action canceled
and so on so because I'm smart I'm gonna
say go to traces and say where message
end with canceled right and then order
by date timestamp and that's it
and this will work I will get exactly
what business asks and they will be
happy and I'm gonna get the bonus and
everyone will sleep very well at night
however when they come back and they say
you know that happened again and now we
actually need to know the number or the
payment ID of what happened to that
payment until it was canceled
you're gonna be very sad because if
that's all you have you're gonna have to
write some very nasty Rejects and try to
filter things and it's just not going to
work
but now let's do this let's utilize
structure logging
so let's say logar.log information to
log an information log and instead of
using that dollar sign in the beginning
is string interpolation let's just say
payment with ID Kelly braces payment ID
failed with status payment status and
then I have the ID and the status as
secondary parameters they're not part of
the string they're separate
I will still if I push this into
application insights have a very nice
set of logs person very nice set of
traces
the difference is that if I expand each
of these entries now what I can see is
this so not only do I have the computed
string but I also have the original
format I have the payment ID I have the
payment status as individual parameters
and what can you do with these
parameters well
you can filter them you can use them you
can go and say traces where custom
dimensions and by the way this is
universal to any login provider so
all of them will allow you to somehow
search for them
and give me everything about the payment
that was canceled so as long as that
naming that you gave to this parameter
is consistent throughout the application
and I should say
hopefully if you have a distributed
system throughout the whole system
that you can correlate everything and
see what happened everywhere you can
even go deeper if you want to use
original format and check for any Logs
with that format you can do that if
you're using the eventid.net ads by
default at least in the app inside
provider then you can use that as well
because the message can actually change
and that can cause issues
um
but this is a way way better solution
but you're probably going to say Nick
this is still boxing
and you're right
at this point we're still boxing but we
fixed the part where we allocate a new
string every time we're just gonna
allocate that single template and then
of course it's up to the provider to
know what it's going to do with that
string but if the provider is optimized
it will actually save you quite a bit of
memory in strings which is more
important than just boxing a couple of
value types the ID and the status in
this case both of them are relatively
cheap
so I shall use structure logging and
give good names to my parameters
consistent names Universal names you
don't want to have payment ID called ID
here payment ID here and payment
identifier there just use the exact same
name everywhere
but you might say
hey Nick I'm using cellular does this
all apply to me how many of you use
serialogue as you raise your hands
it's a great Library that's another joke
I actually really really like it
there's two ways of doing cellular
there is the raw side logger where you
just load configuration and you enrich
it if you want and so on and then you
create a logger and then you just add
this single logger into your application
and you keep using it throughout the
application and then there's the other
one where you have the
serialog.extensions Dot Login approach
where you set the static logger and then
you use the add login parameter to add
cell log in your application now
both of them have pros and cons the
first one will be more performant
because it's detached by the built-in
logger the second one will actually add
cellulog as one of the providers of
logging so what you want to do in that
situation is clear everything else and
only have cellulog and then cellular can
have its own providers
this will all get quite irrelevant as we
go through the topic but there are
performance differences depending on
which side you are on them
now the good thing about serolog is that
very early they actually prevented
boxing
and they're preventing it in the same
way that C sharp is trying to prevent it
in C sharp 10 onwards with string
intervalation and that is by providing
methods like information write error
whatever that have n amount of generic
parameters so we have the template as
the first parameter and they actually do
call it template we don't call it
message to confuse people
sorry I got a bit heated there
and they pre-created an N amount I think
all the way to five six or seven
methods that have generic parameters
and this will prevent boxing
only doesn't then
let's talk about the log level for a
second because that's relevant
in Microsoft or the Microsoft vlogger
you have the enum called log level and
you have Trace debug information warning
error critical and then in the end they
said
we don't have the nun so they added
that six
so if anything comes after that we're
screwed
the reason why they did it just pulling
the leg is because when you're
configuring your log level in your
application if you set it to none six
then everything else is basically
shadowed so that's it just looks weird
to me just make it nullable come on
then you have cell log which goes with
verbose debug information iron and fatal
fatal really a bit Grim isn't it
I think it's made by a German guy so it
makes sense
but fundamentally they mean the exact
same things Trace debug information
warning error fatal
Trace is just a very small information
that's not supposed to be or and verbose
that's not supposed to be shared with
anybody really including your login
provider if you want to push it
somewhere it would have sensitive
information debug is as the name implies
for you to debug your application
usually you don't push it but you can
information is informational it gives
you something about your app warning is
oh there's something going on and maybe
you want to take you know take a look
here error is something broke but your
app is still running critical is
something broke call 911 or whatever you
have uh whoever's on call
all that can be configured in your
application settings.json or your login
provide or your settings provider so you
probably have seen this because it comes
with every goddamn template in c-sharp
so the default log level is information
for everything but then you can have log
categories like microsoft.asp.net core
to say that anything under that category
has a different level
and then when you use logarithmation or
logger.loginformation that Associates a
specific log level with that message and
that's how c-sharp knows to display it
or send it to your provider or not
now
I want to talk about the dot the the
Microsoft logger a bit because the
Microsoft logger looks like this we have
an easy enabled check to see if the log
level is enabled and if it is not
enabled we're not going to push the log
and that's great because it means you're
going to do less work you don't you know
if something is debug and you have
information well why would I even worry
about it
but the problem is that at this point
we've already boxed those arguments so
yes it is optimized but it is not as
optimized as it could be
and that's where the center log logger
comes in from a very very stage they did
the following they said when I write
this I'm going to use generics I'm still
going to have that is enabled log level
check but I'm only going to write and
box which boxing is inevitable in this
case at least with the tooling we had at
the time I'm only going to do the boxing
if I know that the log level is enabled
so this will prevent unnecessary work
what you can do as well with the
built-in Microsoft logger is to write
your own methods to describe what each
thing should do so if you want to log a
payment file you can make a load payment
file method because you're going to have
the good and the status as compile time
parameters it's not going to be any
boxing and you can say if log level is
not enabled then return early and you're
going to prevent the Box again and
necessary work
so
rule number four I shall prevent
unnecessary boxing for inactive log
levels now you might have seen what I
just showed you before and you might say
God I have to make one method per thing
I want to log how is that even that
doesn't scale and you're right and the
good thing about this is that Microsoft
also knows it because Microsoft turns
out they also write code in.net and they
have been very hard at work
they made a logging Source generator so
instead of you having they acknowledge
that yeah that thing I just showed you
make a method per log message is the way
to go
but it's also very very tedious to do so
what they did is they gave us this
tooling where you can slap this into a
partial static class and you can add the
logger message attribute you can specify
log level message event ID a bunch of
different other things and then all you
need to do is you set the message
you give it a name and behind the scenes
a magic sword generator we'll take a
look at this and say oh I know what to
do with this I can write some code that
does all this so you don't have to and I
can make it as optimized as I can and in
many ways more optimize that you ever
could because it has access to things
that your code doesn't internal things
so you write the first line and you get
the last line
and it's the exact same log entry as
before you still have your message you
still keep your original format you have
an event name event ID payment ID all
that is still there but why is it
awesome and why it is my preferred way
of doing this type of thing well it is
awesome because all this code is written
for you that's exactly what's going to
happen behind the scenes now a bit of a
spoiler in.net 8 is actually changes to
be optimized even further so I think if
your logs have less than four or three
parameters
um different type of code will be
generated
but let's talk about what is current
right now and it's this let's take a
look at each thing individually first
the logger is a neighboring message or
check is at the very top of the method
so Microsoft acknowledges that yeah you
don't want to do any work without
needing to do the work and that's not
negotiable have it there do it then you
have a log callback that actually as you
can see here is a static read-only
action that accepts an eye logger good a
string and an exception which is not
level
so it sort of caches in a way the
logging action with generics as you're
gonna see here in this logger message
dot defined method which is ultimately
what behind the scenes makes logging so
optimized so we have all that and we can
customize something we can say for
example skip the enable check and so on
but we didn't have to write a single
line of this we just well we did write a
single line I'm lying did you solve the
single line but that's what the compiler
will write for us
and if we go deeper into
loggermessage.define you'll see that
there's more optimizations going on with
more generics more that log values thing
that will only be allocated on the stack
and then this check to say okay do we
want to skip a second enable checked or
not it's all just very very tight very
very optimized and you shall consider
using certain rated loggers especially
for your hot Buffs I'm not saying go
ahead and use them everywhere because
that can get tedious you're going to
have a file where you can just create
these entries and maybe you know
performance is contextually doesn't mean
the same thing for everyone so if you
have a hot path consider this maybe you
don't want to use it everywhere
now one thing I want to talk about is
custom string interpolation handlers
because when we got this type of tooling
from c-sharp and n.net we also got the
ability to make our own of this
and this is where me and a few other
people actually have tried to fly too
close to the Sun
so I'll tell you a bit of a of a
cautionary tale about this
you can technically if you want if you
if you're smart about this and you say
Okay since I have this interpolation
Handler I could get the name and the age
the the strings of those things at
compile time and use them as parameters
in my logging to prevent having to
create message templates so keep using
string interpolation
so you could do that by creating a
refract call it login templated Handler
slap interpolated string Handler
attribute on it and then you use the
default one internally to make sort of a
facade of a proxy
and if you do all that you can create
your own append formatted method because
there's no interface to actually follow
this is done using duct typing
and if you do that you're going to get
this or something like this where you
have a color argument expression I don't
know how many of you know of this
attribute but it will allow you to
capture the compile time name of
whatever parameter you pass in which
means that
and and then of course I can make my own
sort of overload of login information
and if I do that you see that my
parameter is a ref of logging in the
polluted string Handler this means that
basically I'm accepting an interpolated
string that is all there is to it so if
you make around 100 like this then that
method can accept this thing and if that
method accepts this thing then what's
going to happen when I push it into
obligation insights is the following as
you can see in the custom Dimensions I
have the ID the value and the name both
captured and the status now see they're
matching their low lower case so it's
exactly what I had when I pushed the
thing into whatever environment
the problem with this approach is that
anything you put in there will actually
be pushed if you have good dot new good
that thing the text going.new good will
be pushed if you have get status the
thing will be posted if you have a
method the whole thing it will be pushed
good luck keeping consistency between
your argument names and good luck
filtering all that it's not going to
happen there are ways to prevent it if
you really want to go about it by
controlling it through you writing an
analyzer code analyzer but then at this
point I would question your sanity and
my sanity because I try to do this took
a long time bad idea
don't do this control your parameter
names because even if you get them to be
consistent in your single application
you might not get them to be consistent
everywhere in your system and we really
really want that so
log payment error as you can see here
event ID all that controlled in your
application and you're going to be very
very happy so
rule number six I shall not try to get
too clever with tooling and that's a
rule for me actually
and I'm just sharing with you
I want to go back to the log level for a
second because there's more behind the
scenes about this parameter
so we established what it is we
associate each log entry with a log
level to help us filter and so on
and the default log level in dotnet is
information now if you have a separate
namespace or a separate log category as
they call them you can Define it as it
is or as you want by default this is
warning if I go ahead and I change this
microsoft.asp.net core to information
then what I'm going to see in the
asp.net core application in a single
request mind you is this
those are little strings that are going
to be created and the only thing I
really care about here is this one which
is me saying Retreat quote for currency
is this in this many milliseconds
if you keep
or you don't fine-tune your log levels
and your categories you're going to end
up with a lot of crap in your login
provider for example I did ask you if
any of you are using datadog now for
those of you who are not using datadog
which in case you don't know also a sort
of a Telemetry login Pro destination
sort of thing where you can have apms
and if you go to check out your
subscription uh during payment you're
greeted with four payment methods it is
Visa Mastercard American Express and
this one this is a kidney it can get
very expensive very very expensive and
logs are one of the things that really
make it to be
incredibly expensive in fact because
we're a big client we're Consulting with
them and one of the things they said was
have you considered lowering your log
level because think about it you're
pushing your logs of log level
information even not not just the
Microsoft expanded core all of your logs
to your login provider but at which
point do you go and say I'm going to
take a look at the logs you're going to
take a look at the logs when they fail
you're not going to wake up a morning
and be like you know how I'm feeling I'm
feeling take a look at the logs today
like you never I've never done it I've
never done it I did do it when things
went wrong but that's about it
so you should treat them as just one of
your tools and what I would argue is
that your information log level default
log level doesn't need to be information
the counter argument of course is that
what happens when eventually something
does fail and you need to trace the
whole lifetime of request and that is a
very valid argument now a bit of
attention I'm working on a tool that
actually fixes that uses um the new
interceptors coming in.net that will
allow you to say if something went wrong
here
these are all the buffered logs before
in this scope and you can choose to
obtain to also ship everything before
the failure for that request I don't
know when I'm going to launch that or if
we're going to make a video for that so
subscribe to take a look at it
but there are ways around it so you
should Twitter logs are just a single
tool and then you use other things like
metrics traces spans whatever to see if
your application is working or not
because some people say I'm using logs
just to see that there's a flow of
requests coming in to say that my app is
working that's not what logs are for so
be very very careful this is bad
so rule number seven I shall consider
using warning as the default Logo level
this doesn't have to be on everywhere
you can start playing around with this
by just configuring some of your load
categories the ones you feel comfortable
with to a higher log level and then see
how that goes and also for the love of
God also use metrics in your
applications in what whichever capacity
you can not everything needs to be in a
log in fact most things don't need to be
in a log
now I want to talk about this quote
because
well you might be thinking of this quote
as I'm giving this talk because I'm
talking about performance quite a bit
I'm sure many many of you have heard of
it pretty much optimization is the root
of all evil now in my opinion the root
of all evil is people taking this quote
and misinterpreting it for their own
purpose
and what many people do with this quote
is that they use it as a way to just
ditch any responsibility of writing good
software it doesn't have to be
performant it just has to do the right
thing and do it well
let's think about why do we log
so ultimately and you might have had or
thought of this as I've been going
through we're really logging to tell a
good story it's the story usually of
what happened to a request
and
good stories end in tragedy
for some people
um but once you want to take a look at
are usually the ones that do end in
tragedy
and think of this their books but
they're also good books do you see a
difference here now out of all these
these two books you can probably gain
the same knowledge the same available
knowledge one of them is very dense very
big I mean they're both in JavaScript so
but one of them is very very small and
only gives you the good parts
logs should be like that you can have a
login provider that ends up like the
first book the one you want to have is
the second
what I like to do with my logs is I like
to be what we call in Greece laconic now
I don't know how many of you know the
word I thought nobody knew of the word
laconic and then I gave this talk in
Romania and everyone knew of the word
Electronics I'm not going to assume
anything
um but what you need to know is that
this word has to do with Spartans not
these ones not these ones these ones
so the OG Spartans they I have to censor
it sorry
the original Spartans
um the location of Laconia is where
Sparta is
um were known for the laconism and what
laconic means is to use a very few words
to express yourself
so this is how I like to think about
logging not just the log message but
each individual message each message is
me saying this happened and this
happened and this happened that this
happened how many of these happens can I
eliminate to tell you the exact same
story
and that's how I like to think about it
accurate descriptive and short messages
system consistent parameter names
and properly utilized log levels
so my final rule rule number eight is I
shall log only what's necessary to tell
a good story
and that's it
thank you very much and keep coding
[Applause]